liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir
begrüßen sie um kurz nach halb acht an
diesem donnerstag und falls sie gerade
erst aufgewacht sind ja es sind
nachrichten mit denen da wollten wir
eigentlich nicht aufwachen seit wenigen
stunden führte putin tatsächlich krieg
in der ukraine eine militär operation
hat dort begonnen es ist ein tag den man
sich wirklich nicht wünscht und
bundeskanzler scholz hat sich zum
konflikt schon geäußert hat gesagt das
ist ein schrecklicher tag für die
ukraine und ein schwarzer für europa
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
kündigt eine scharfe reaktion an und
konsequenzen für den kreml ähnlich
äußert sich auch us-präsident beiden und
frankreichs präsident und auch der
vizekanzler habe mit ihm werden wir
später noch sprechen wollen uns aber
jetzt nach moskau bewegen und zwar zu
unserer korrespondentin anna feist
wladimir putin hat diese militärische
eskalation via tv angekündigt anna
vielleicht können sie uns das noch mal
zusammenfassen
ja und 5 uhr 30 in moskau zeit also um 3
uhr 30 deutscher zeit gab es hier eine
halbstündige fernsehansprache durch
vladimir putin
dort kündigte er eben eine
militäroffensive in der ukraine an die
rechtfertigung in dieser
fernsehansprache war der angebliche
völkermord der an den russischstämmigen
bürgern im osten der ukraine stattfindet
und angeblich hätten die prorussischen
separatisten putin um hilfe gebeten im
kampf um den don bass gegen das
ukrainische militär und in dieser
fernsehansprache forderte putin die
ukraine auf die waffen niederzulegen
dann würde es auch kein schlachtfeld
geben und er machte keine angaben zu
größe und umfang des einsatzes
mittlerweile wissen wir von russischen
raketen beschuss in der gesamten ukraine
unter anderem wurden gemeldet als wurde
von belarus aus angegriffen von der krim
aus es habe zwei explosionen in der
hafenstadt mahut wohl am rande des
donners gegeben außerdem
kam es zu beschuss in lyon f also in
lemberg im westen der ukraine und in
kiew soll ein munitionsdepot in flammen
stehen begleitet wurden diese angriffe
wohl auch von mehreren cyber angriffen
soeben haben wir noch eine meldung
bekommen nämlich von der russischen
nachrichtenagentur interfax die berief
sich auf
verteidigungsministerium und sagte dass
die militärische infrastruktur der
ukrainischen luftwaffenstützpunkte
zerstört worden sein anna dieser krieg
ist jetzt leider eingetreten und es ist
auch ein krieg der information es ist
alles sehr sehr schwer zu verifizieren
ob das jetzt stimmt was beide seiten da
gerade von sich geben fest steht weil
das zeigen auch bilder unseres partner
senders cnn ist dass russisches militär
mit panzern von belarus aus in die
ukraine rollt man hört außerdem auch von
bombenexplosionen und raketenbeschuss
auf mehrere städte in der ukraine
der westen hat sich jetzt schon vielfach
geäußert und reagiert und scharfe
sanktionen angekündigt und konsequenzen
vielleicht können sie uns was über die
reaktionen die russischen reaktionen auf
diese sanktions ankündigungen sagen
ja die russischen reaktionen sind bisher
an diesem morgen sehr verhalten also
weder in den zeitungen ist darüber
bisher viel zu lesen sie wurden einfach
auch vor der fernsehansprache gedruckt
deswegen ist das wahrscheinlich kein
wunder und auch sonst hat man hier
bisher wenig aber es ist schon so dass
diese sanktion von russischer seite
belächelt werden putin geht davon aus
dass man sich sowieso wieder mit ihm an
den verhandlungstisch setzen werde wenn
man mit ihm verhandeln wolle genau das
ist so ein bisschen die reaktion die wir
von hier haben die sektion schüchtern
zumindest bisher nicht ein er ist ja
eigentlich obwohl man das jetzt nicht
denkt weil man denkt so aus westlicher
perspektive wie kann er so einen schritt
jetzt machen wo er doch dann
international völlig isoliert ist aber
er hat das offenbar eingepreist die
reaktionen des westens wir sind gespannt
wie das weitergeht das erste vielen dank
live aus moskau war das annafest